donald trump is back on the campaign
trail
he held a rally on january 15th
and he leaned into
a major racial issue that's going on
right now
namely
that white people are being
discriminated against when it comes to
treatment for kovid in many states as a
result of guidance issued by the
national government by the fda here's
donald trump
just denigrating white people to
determine who lives and who dies if
you're white
you don't get the vaccine or if you're
white you don't get therapeutics
it's unbelievable to think this
and nobody wants this
black people don't want it white people
don't want it nobody wants it
it's not even believable you saw this a
week ago where it came out nobody can
even believe it they don't even talk
about it and they don't want to talk
about it because they know
it doesn't work very well for them but
the wall street journal described the
practice
race-based preferential
covet treatments and that's what it is
you get it based on race
in fact in new york state if you're
white
you have to go to the back of the line
to get medical help think of it if
you're white you go right to the back of
the line
this is
really
important
for donald trump to point out that
because this is a
grievous issue that's going on in and of
itself and it's really smart politics so
what the left is trying to do now is
they're denying that what he said is
true which is why trump cites the wall
street journal very credible mainstream
news source
we covered it on this show two weeks ago
you're seeing preferential treatment for
non-white groups and you're seeing
whites discriminated against in a number
of states in part this is because the
fda has
said that there is a disparate impact
there's a disproportionate
negative effect of kovid on marginalized
communities and they define marginalized
communities as non-white communities and
so they get to go further up in the line
than the white people do this is
absolutely real it's really happening
credible credible authoritative
mainstream news sources even are
reporting on it so trump is citing that
he's saying you can't fact-check me on
this and it's it's
wrong it's a it's a
wrong thing to do and people of all
races know that it's wrong are you
spending too much money on gas
yes you are i know that you are by
definition you are if you have not yet
downloaded
the getupside app it is a free app that
will allow you to make up to 25 cents
cash back for every gallon of gas every
time you fill up very simple you go to
your app store you download the free app
and then you use promo code knowles
guess what happens then not only will
you get 25 cents cash back for every
gallon you fill up
you'll get another 25 cents cash back
for every gallon you fill up on your
first tank
50 cents per gallon cash back on your
first tank when you use get upside and
promo code knolls some people who drive
a lot are making as much as two to three
hundred dollars a year in cash back
that's a lot of money no catch only cash
back gets added right to your bank
account or if you prefer paypal or an
e-gift card for amazon and other brands
head on over right now
download the free get upside app and use
promo code nullscanwlis to get up to 50
cents per gallon cashback on your first
tank with code
knowles
so he's not just saying that this is
white grievance and it's the white
people versus the black people or versus
the hispanic people versus the it's not
all decent people of all races can agree
that it is wrong to deny someone medical
care on the basis of their race
this is not a black and white it is a
black and white issue in as much as it's
very clear
and all decent white black asian
hispanic people know that it's it's the
wrong thing to do
and i think this will play very well on
the campaign trail
but it's also and this is the part that
a lot of people are missing this is also
a really smart move from trump because
it gets him out of his toughest
political position right now namely that
he owns the vaccine issue he developed
the vaccines he has promoted the
vaccines and a lot of his base doesn't
really like the vaccines one because the
vaccines do not do all of the things
that joe biden and dr fauci and rochelle
wolenski said that they would do
biden fauci wallenski all said the
vaccines would prevent infection and
transmission of the virus and the
vaccines don't
do that so
now then they changed their story and
they said well no actually the vet the
vaccines do not prevent transmission and
infection but they do mitigate the
symptoms and so they keep moving the
goalposts and keep changing their
stories and the base is highly skeptical
of that and they have some moral
objections to the vaccines and they
obviously object to the vaccine mandates
which trump has said he opposes but he's
still got to own the vaccines so how's
he going to get him out himself out of
this predicament
he can say
that the left is trying to deny you
medical care
he's saying there
the the left is trying to take this good
thing away from you and so it just
softens the vaccine issue it's a
political master stroke that very few
people have picked up on but it's the
first it's the first maneuver trump has
made on this vaccine covid policy issue
in months and months and months that i
think is actually going to move the ball
in the right direction so what's the
response from
from the left the left is calling him
racist the left is denying that it's
happening the lev but
everyone sees through that this is a
really strong issue a lot of republicans
should campaign on i'm so glad you like
that clip
i thought it was good work
i thought it was pretty interesting i
it's look i'm with you is what i'm
saying we both appreciated that clip so
you gotta subscribe
you gotta ring that bell get those
notifications for all the new videos
that come out and head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
type in the michael knowles show
subscribe
leave a five star review i appreciate it
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]